welcome back to CBS mornings we continue
our team coverage of the upcoming
election America decides looking at
races across the country that could
determine who controls Congress one of
them is in Nevada where the CBS News
Battleground tracker just released shows
Democratic senator Catherine Cortez
masto locked in a close re-election race
with Republican Adam lachsold Lilia
Luciano is on the ground in Nevada
asking Latinos a fast-growing share of
Voters what's influencing their
decisions
foreign
states in the Nevada midterm races are
high and odds are Latinos will decide
making up 20 percent of the state's
electorate Governor House and Senate
candidates are reaching out to secure
votes among the fastest growing minority
moves are more powerful and effective in
eliciting those votes than the state's
Culinary Union knocking on more than a
million doors ahead of this election why
are you doing this
I'm doing this because I think the one
of the issues that I'm most concerned
about is the housing right now I wish it
wasn't so expensive and the Republicans
are trying to take away the freedom this
year the union endorsed incumbent
Democratic senator Catherine Cortez
masto who made history as the first
Latina ever in the Senate but the CBS
News Battleground tracker shows her
statistically tied with her opponent
former Nevada attorney general Adam
laxalt so even after hours Cortez masto
is making the rounds my focus is on
nevadans that's always been my priority
whether it's a small business owner like
you have here
or it's families that are one every
opportunity to succeed for themselves
and their kids that's what it's about
for me that's the work that I get to do
in the Senate every day for a state hit
hard by covet closures with inflation
and gas prices among the highest in the
country voting in this election is about
nothing more than making ends meet says
laxalt's advisor Jesus Marquez Latinos
in the past used to think that okay we
need to vote for a Latina or a Latino
but now it doesn't matter if whether
it's Latino or not as long as it takes
care of the problems I can only tell you
yeah that what I hear from Nevadas and
Latinos and it it really is the same
story for all of us which is that
American Dream
you know it is the opportunity to
succeed but her opponent has a fierce
finger pointed at Democrats as to why
that dream is Out Of Reach yeah tell him
look outside and everything their
experience is a direct result of Joe
Biden and Senator Catherine Cortez masto
all the pain they're feeling today at
the pump at the grocery store in their
family budgets is a direct result of
policy they're killing the American
dream there's work that I've been able
to do with in conjunction with them to
start figuring how we lower those costs
because we know it's squeezing families
I think the inflation reduction Act was
a great first start but I do think
absolutely there's more that we can do
together
that focus on cost of living is
something that we're seeing not just
here in Nevada but across the country
but I'll tell you something about voters
here they know the high stakes of this
Senate race according to our CBS News
Battleground tracker 8 and 10 voters
here see their vote as gaining their
party control of the senate in
Washington Tony
all right Luciano for us in Nevada thank
you very much